( intro music )
( muffled radio noises )
( swooshing sound )
( electronic hum )
( audience applause )
Well I'm really
happy to be here
with everybody this
evening and share with you
a bit of a potpourri
from an alien planet.
From an alien planet
that is near and dear
to our hearts because
we live on it.
And because we live on it,
we think we know about it.
But the truth is
that there are huge,
vast tracks of the
surface and particularly
the subsurface that are
really unknown to us.
And so each one of
these little planet-lets
that go to make up our
planet actually harbors
life forms and conditions
that are radically different
from what we experience
on the surface.
And my way of substituting
for getting into
my rocket ship and cruising
the galaxy looking for
cool life forms, which is
what I grew up wanting to do,
is to have stayed
closer to home because
I don't have a rocket
ship yet, come on NASA.
( audience laughter )
And try to explore templates
for the kind of life that
we might find on the planets
in our own solar system
and what kinds of signatures
would those leave.
Well, National
Geographic has played
a big role in my life.
And I had my first
magazine subscription
as a little kid, courtesy
of my cousin in 1968.
Early on in my
attention to caves,
they sponsored some of
our work, and this is
the centerfold from
the January 2000 issue.
I actually was able to
be a centerfold model.
( audience laughter )
And looking as glamorous
as I usually look
in these kinds of
deals, and there I am
with Diana Northup
and Mike Spilde,
two colleagues from the
University of New Mexico,
and I'm diving for phlegm ball
mats totally suited up.
If you've read the
magazine article
this time around you
will know that we are
still working on that
system 15 years later
and we are still mystified
by the tremendous
amount of biological
activity in what is to us
an extremely toxic environment.
This is why we're all duded up,
because we are kind
of life form, humans,
and higher animals find
this kind of environment
very toxic.
But we are still
looking at snottites,
these are the famous snottites.
And I'm gazing lovingly at them.
( audience laughter )
And taking samples of them,
which we will haul
back to the lab
and then try to poke
them with sticks
and get them to grow and look
at their DNA guts
and all that kind of stuff.
But this is not where my
caving career started.
It actually also
started by way of
a National Geographic special.
It was called "Mysteries
Underground" in 1992.
And that same year, with
several other colleagues,
I had published a
paper suggesting that
the best place to
look for life on Mars
was not on the surface of Mars,
but would be in the subsurface.
And I was looking for a way
to get into the subsurface
of Earth
to see what we could find
down there.
And I was way too poor
to actually do drilling.
We couldn't get
anybody to pay for it,
and we saw this National
Geographic special,
and it said a couple of
really important things
about the cave.
It said it was pristine,
that it had been dug into,
which meant less contamination.
That it had a lot of sulfur,
and we already knew
that Mars was a very
sulfur-rich planet.
And the third thing was
that one of the geologists
from the USGS Geological Survey
said that he thought he
had seen some kind of
little microbial life forms
on some of the formations.
And so we were sold,
and we called him
up and we said,
"You don't know us
but we're from NASA
and we'd like to
go into your cave."
So we trained for
three hours ( laughs ),
which if we had known
then what we know now,
of course this was
completely nuts,
and then we went
on an expedition
for five days into this cave.
Now this cave is a huge system.
It's 138 miles of
mapped passage so far.
And exploration
is still underway.
Of course we were captivated by
many of the scenes that you see.
This is a beautiful
image of what's known
as the Chandelier Ballroom.
These are big selenite crystals.
But really the quarry
that I am always after
is shown in these
orange materials
behind where the
young man is standing.
This brown stuff in the middle,
it's not as spectacular,
but this is where
the real quarry lay.
And there are some of
my little friends now.
These are all
microorganism types
that are unknown to science.
In fact, virtually everything
we find in the subsurface
is unknown in the databases
that we have
of surface life forms.
The tiny ones there,
we call them the tiny guys,
isn't that original?
( audience laughter )
These guys are about
100 nanometers across.
One of your hairs is about
a 100 micrometers across,
so this is a thousand
times smaller than that.
And these are some of
the smallest life forms
that are clearly
growing and alive
that have ever been found.
The ones with hairy
bits sticking off them,
we call them smurfs ( laughs )
for obvious reasons.
And then the others
are the death stars.
( audience laughter )
Well these are just
a few of the microbial forms
that we see in the subsurface.
And this is really
what got us going,
and really caused me
to focus my career
from a lot of the
surface extreme systems
that I had been
looking at up until
that point in my career.
I just wanna dazzle you
with cool stuff, okay?
So one of the amazing
things about caves
is just how big the
spaces can be underground.
Here's a couple of examples.
And if you've never
been to Carlsbad
or Mammoth Cave
or any of the beautiful
show caves around the world,
this is probably what
you are looking at.
Something like that.
But there are many
other peculiar
and amazing structures.
So, see all
that white material
when you're actually there
it sort of sparkles like sugar.
There's 18 kilometers of
this river underground.
This is Snowy River
in Fort Stanton Cave,
about only an hour and a half
away from my campus.
But the thing that
gets us about this
is not just the
spectacular mineralogy,
but all those dark
streaks on the wall.
That's where the real action is.
And you can almost
hear them calling.
They're saying, "Hey, hey,
stupid, we're up here."
( audience laughter )
In their tiny little
microbial voices.
( audience laughter )
And when we take
samples of those,
we can find that
sure enough they are
made by bacteria that
make their living
off a chemical
transformation of minerals
that contain the
element manganese.
This is a pretty exotic
way of making your living.
They don't eat sandwiches
for lunch like we do,
they eat rock and minerals.
And this is ubiquitous
in these kinds of systems.
This is one of my
colleagues crawling through
some of that beautiful
white material.
In this material,
besides its beauty,
it also contains
fossilized microorganisms.
So we can see that
the cave is preserving
not only the live guys,
that we can go in
and look for now,
but also the potential
for preserving that material
into the future to be tested.
This is a potpourri of
some of our little friends.
The upper left hand
is spots of goo
and little colonies,
and all of that is alive.
There are probably two
or three thousand strains
of microbes in there,
not a single one of which
is very closely related to
anything on the surface.
This is in a lava
tube cave in Hawaii.
The upper right hand side is
what under some
circumstances would just
turn into an ordinary
stalagmite dripping water,
saturated with mineral, and
yet in some circumstances
it turns into nests of
so-called cave pearls.
Why?
We think it's biology.
We think it's the gooey
biofilm that microbes produce
that actually causes
that to occur.
In a mine in northern Minnesota,
called the Soudan mine,
there are bore holes
very narrow
that go down
to much deeper levels.
And when you sample
those deeper levels,
you still find microorganisms.
They are even more exotic
in making their living
in a totally
non-oxygen environment.
This is a salty, briny iron
mush that they're living in.
And you can see little
bubbles of their activity
coming up from below.
In that same mine, on a
March afternoon in 1962,
the miners were told
that the mine closed,
and they threw down all their
stuff and left in disgust.
50 years later, what we
find are these structures
that you can see, this
tower of dark material,
actually growing on one
of those miner's jackets
that had been
discarded on that day.
And this is entirely
composed of iron
and manganese-utilizing
microorganisms
and the minerals
that they excrete.
If you go to southeast
Alaska and are lucky enough
to be able to find one of
the caves that exist there
in the Tongass National Forest,
and you take a sample
of some of the material
there and you bring it
back to the laboratory
and look at it with a
scanning electron microscope,
you will see this beautiful
forest of crystals.
All of those filamentous
things that you see
weaving through
them are microbes,
and the microbes
are facilitating
the creation of these
beautiful structures.
Here, these pool, out
of which these fluffy
foof balls, or poof
balls we call them.
This is the Poof Ball Sea.
And this is a system
that is always
right around or below freezing.
So you can see that
the temperature range
within which we can
operate is really great.
This system is in Ukraine.
This is one of the
largest gypsum caves,
in the rock type
gypsum, in the world.
It's between 90 and 100
kilometers of passage,
so it's a very big system.
And it's covered by these
screaming red towers
that look sort of
like stalagmites.
And the color is
indeed as brilliant,
as you can see from the
knife that's in the picture.
And when we look
at those with
an electron microscope,
we see this is not just mineral,
that it is composed
of these tulip-shaped
microorganisms all glued
together with iron compounds.
We don't know who those are.
Even something like granite,
and this shows a granite
cave in northern Spain
with colleagues from Spain
and Portugal and Brazil.
Just looks like an
ordinary granite surface.
But actually the granite
itself is sort of
a yellow color, and that
gray color that you're seeing
is really composed
of these little guys.
So fluffy strings of bacteria
are making their living on
the inside of this granite cave.
And they are producing
beautiful little
silica-containing speleothems,
or decorations as
they're called.
Tiny little stalactites
and stalagmites.
And they are doing that
because by their very
life processes they're helping
to dissolve that granite.
So individually
they're very tiny,
but in the aggregate
they're incredibly powerful.
Even in ice, which is
particularly important
when we come to think
about icy bodies
in our own solar system
and the potential
presence of life
in those systems.
This is Aaron Curtis, one
of our graduate students
at New Mexico Tech, who's
doing his dissertation work
on the ice caves
around the volcano
Mount Erebus in Antarctica.
And not only are these
magnificent caves
with beautiful decorations
in them just like
you would find in
a limestone cave perhaps,
but there are also life forms
in those ices.
Here's one that looks
like a twisted candy cane.
So there is nowhere
that is bug free.
( audience laughter )
No matter what you
hear on TV about
how you should live
a germ-free life,
you should not believe that.
( audience laughter )
I wanted to give you
a glimpse of a mystery
that we are pursuing
and have been pursuing
for about 15 years.
And you can see some of
the macroscopic evidences
of it in this beautiful
little cave decoration here.
This is a copper mineral
called chrysocolla,
and it is a
beautiful blue color.
And when we first saw
these we were entranced
and thought, "Gee, they
seem to be gooey",
and they were gooey.
And we took samples of
them and lo and behold
they had many
microorganisms in them.
Since this initial effort,
we found them
in many different caves
around the world.
And they often contain
structures that look like this.
These look like empty
mesh stockings, right?
But we don't know what they are.
We don't know what kind
of life form they are.
They all have the same pattern,
although there are variations.
And now we've found
them in probably about
50 or 60 different
caves around the world
in all different
kinds of chemistries,
all different kinds
of temperatures.
All different circumstances.
Some are shallow, some are deep.
We don't know who these are.
They're not fungi,
they're not amoebas,
they're not bacteria.
We don't know.
So 15 years of pursuing
what I think of
as the wild boojum right
here on this planet,
even with all of the
science that we have
at our disposal, and
we still have aliens
right here underneath our feet.
I want to end with
this spectacular image
by a wonderful cave
photographer, Carsten Peter.
This is the Naica system
in Chihuahua in Mexico.
National Geographic
has done a wonderful
article on that in 2008.
There have been two
National Geographic
television specials
that we've been
privileged to participate in.
And yes, those
crystals are that big.
And the reason that we're
in these little orange suits
is not to keep us warm
as you might think,
but to actually keep us
cool enough to work in there.
So are essentially in
suits packed in ice
in order to keep us from
dying from the heat in there.
The heat ranges from
about 105 degrees
to perhaps well over
140 degrees Fahrenheit.
And this is just not
survivable for humans.
And yet this entire system
has microbes everywhere.
It has them in the walls,
on that orange material.
And particularly
interesting to us,
it has them in little
tiny fluid pockets
within the giant crystals.
And because the crystal
growth rate has been
measured and also age
dated, we know
that the samples that we were
able to take in some of those
crystals are at a
time depth of between
about 10 and perhaps
about 50,000 years.
So we have been able
to go into the crystals
and use these little
pockets of time capsules.
And not only were
we able to find DNA
and organic remains
of microorganisms,
but we were able to
actually bring a lot of them
into culture alive.
So we're very excited
about this because
this shows that
microorganisms can tolerate
significant periods of time,
geologically significant
periods of time,
in a state of
relative inactivity,
and yet still remain viable,
still remain life-containing,
and still able to be brought
back to life so to speak
once they get released
from these materials.
So our own mini solar
system underneath our feet
is acting as practice
really as we try to do
what my colleagues
have suggested.
And that is take our
knowledge, take our science,
take our melding of
the discipline of science
with the magic of
exploration and the beauties
of what we see and
what we experience
and combine those
together in order to
advance our knowledge
of the universe.
So we are right on
the cusp of this
kind of exploration.
And the work that I
and my colleagues do
will hopefully help
to give us models
for how organisms
can make their living
in this amazing
array of planets
that we have in our solar system
and this amazing
array of planets
that we apparently have
in our galaxy and our universe.
Thank you.
( audience applause )
( outro music )